[Música]
la guerra en ucrania está próxima a
cumplir un mes y mientras continúan los
enfrentamientos entre las partes no
dejan a un lado la vía diplomática que
reclama en las negociaciones que se
llevan a cabo con moscú que se
establezca un modelo de neutralidad
propia para su país y no basado en el de
otros países como suecia o austria que
tienen un ejército propio pero no
pertenecen a la otan en la actualidad
hay varios países neutrales en el mundo
o al menos considerados así hablamos de
algunos ejemplos como suecia finlandia
austria la neutralidad sueca por ejemplo
tiene los orígenes a comienzos del siglo
19 y se ha caracterizado su política de
su política exterior durante estos dos
siglos aunque no está incluida en su
constitución por su parte la tradicional
línea de neutralidad y no alineamiento
de finlandia fue impuesta por la urss
con la que perdió dos guerras
consecutivas entre 1939 1944 y en el
caso de austria está obligada a la
neutralidad por el tratado del estado
austríaco de
1955 y por su constitución
en la entrada en alianzas militares y el
establecimiento de bases militares
extranjeras en su territorio en
territorio austríaco para ello entonces
quiero saludar a nuestro primer invitado
del día el sergio garcía director del
centro de investigación sobre extrema
derecha y también relaciones
internacionales gracias sergio por estar
con nosotros en directo américa de
france 24 me preguntó entonces qué tipo
de neutralidad arias quiere rusia
más que una neutralidad lo que busca es
una imposición
donde controle
todo lo que haga ucrania tanto a nivel
nacional como a nivel internacional
véase el listado de obligaciones que le
quiere imponer moscú
quiere imponer en materia lengua quiere
imponer en materia del ejército como
ejército propio pero con limitaciones y
renunciar a la otra renunciar a
bases y bases extranjeras en territorio
ucraniano o recibir el armamento de
otros países en definitiva lo que rusia
quiere es un país títere
porque tiene tanto interés rusia que
ucrania se convierte entonces en un
territorio neutral porque quiere tanto
la neutralidad de ucrania
básicamente porque de esa manera
controlaría lo que rusia denomina su
zona de influencia
además de reconocer a crimea como parte
de rusia y aceptar la soberanía sobre la
república de donets y lugar
porque con estas imposiciones
se situarían a la otan
y a lo que tendríamos que añadir el tema
del control de los gasoductos que pasan
por ucrania dirección europa
que como vemos hoy en día son sumamente
importantes
digamos el zew que sería una opción para
ucrania sería el modelo de austria
sería la de las circunstancias
sería una opción
pese a que el presidente es el ente que
diga que ucrania necesita un tratado
específico donde él
los países que actúen y lleven a cabo
medidas concretas pero incluso sería más
viable de
las similitudes que tienen con finlandia
así ésta se las peticiones que hace
rusia lo que supondría seguramente
recortes muy serios en las libertades de
los ciudadanos ucranianos
cuáles son sergio las diferencias de las
similitudes de estos modelos de
finlandia suecia y austria y esto
obviamente lo trasladamos a cuál le
convendría más a buscar ya poniéndonos
el lado de los negociadores ucranianos
en todo este conflicto
sino si comparamos principalmente a
ucrania con finlandia y suecia la
principal diferencia sería que tanto
finlandia como suecia en nuestros
momentos son miembros de la unión
europea aunque no formen parte de la
otan cosa que ucrania no lo es y ahí es
radica uno de los problemas que ahora
mismo tiene ucrania a la hora de que la
unión europea puede llevar a cabo es un
acto de defensa contra él con ellos no
sergio entonces ucrania digamos puede
ser parte de la unión europea siendo un
territorio neutral como estos dos países
que estábamos hablando digamos cosa
puede ser miembro de la unión europea
pero sin ser miembro luego de la otan
personalmente y creo que ya lo han
referido otros analistas a nivel
internacional en estos momentos sería
algo prácticamente inviable
dadas las obligaciones que le intenta
imponer a rusia a ucrania ya que lo que
busca es un país en donde ellos
controlen quiere decir donde rusia
controle todo lo que se haga dentro de
esas fronteras
creo que en la unión europea no
permitiría eso
serio digamos que estos países que son
considerados neutrales en estos días de
guerra se han
puesto no de alguna manera del lado de
occidente puesto su postura diciendo
pues que no están de acuerdo con esta
guerra que pues van a defender sus
fronteras y toda esta cuestión que
podría pasar porque este cambio de
postura si son unos países llamados
neutrales
sinceramente esperemos que realmente no
pase nada
y que lo que está buscando es disuadir a
las malas intenciones de rusia tanto con
suecia como con finlandia
ya hemos visto que tanto su s como
finlandia han decidido activar la
cláusula
defensa en la unión europea en virtud
del artículo 42 del tratado 2009 debemos
recordar que apenas hace unos días
la portavoz del ministerio de relaciones
exteriores de rusia amenazaba con
consecuencias militares y políticas
perjudiciales sí sí sí se intentaban
unir a la otra tanto finlandia como se
decía
hasta no hace mucho
tanto su s como finlandia eran hacer
vinos de extensor de la neutralidad pero
la invasión de ucrania
y por ello la primera ministra de
finlandia anunció recientemente que su
país buscaría un consenso para una
eventual entrada en la otan
serio qué garantías debe ofrecer rusia a
ucrania para lograr la neutralidad esto
se puede además ser considerado como una
rendición por parte de ucrania
por supuesto sería una rendición por
parte de ucrania que es lo que busca
realmente rusia
rusia debería de respetar los derechos
de los ciudadanos
pero por supuesto
se debe de evitar la injerencia sobre la
soberanía nacional de ucrania que
limitaría previamente su crecimiento y
las relaciones internacionales
con terceros estados e instituciones
internacionales
ya que no solo eliminar cualquier
coqueteo
con poderes occidentales
son asuntos militares de seguridad sino
que el gobierno ruso tendría
y el poder
de marcar la agenda a ucrania por
ejemplo en naciones unidas o por ejemplo
con otros organismos internacionales a
la hora de votar o de posicionarse